A TOUR YOU WON'T WANT TO MISS.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
THE MILITARY NEEDS TO BE
DEPLOYED OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
IMMEDIATELY TO STOP THE CARAVAN
OF THOUSANDS OF ILLEGALS POURING
INTO OUR NATION.
RIGHT NOW IS A VERY DANGEROUS
TIME FOR AMERICANS.
BORDER CONTROL IS ESSENTIAL TO
YOUR SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF
YOUR FAMILY.
THE MILITARY, THE NATIONAL
GUARD, I.C.E., BORDER PATROL AND
DHS NEEDS TO BLOCK THIS CARAVAN
FROM ENTERING OUR NATION.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY ARE ALL
CRIMINALS.
WHAT I AMING A IS, WHO ARE THEY?
WHAT I AM SAYING IS I WANT TO
VET THEM, SCREEN THEM.
I WANT TO FIND OUT HOP AMONG
THEM IS A CRIMINAL, WHO AMONG
THEM IS A GANG MEMBER LIKE THE
NOTORIOUS MS-13 GANG MEMBERS WHO
ARROGANTLY RODE INTO OUR COUNTRY
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS AND THEY
ARE IN NEW YORK BRUTALLY AND
SAVAGE LIP MURDERING INNOCENT
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO IS A
PEDOPHILE, WHO IS A SEX
OFFENDER.
WHO THINKS THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
BEAT HAIR WIVES.
WHO -- BEAT THEIR WIVES.
WHO LIKES A DRIVE DRUNK AND WHO
HAS NO PROBLEM HAULING DWRUGS
FOR THE CARTEL.
IF YOU CAN PROVE YOU ARE NOT A
CRIMINAL, I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU HAVE TO OFFER US.
WHAT DO YOU BRING TO THIS GREAT
NATION.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING CONTRIBUTE.
WHY SHOULD WE BE PROUD TO COUNT
AS AN AMERICA OTHER THAN ADDING
TO THE DEMOCRATS VOTING BLOC AND
CONTINUING THE MOB MENTALITY
THAT YOU ALREADY EXHIBITED YOU
ARE PROFICIENT AT.
IF YOU ARE NOT A CRIMINAL.
I WANT YOU TO GET TO THE BACK OF
THE LINE BEHIND EVERYONE ELSE
WHO WAITED FOR A VISA, CAME HERE
LEGALLY, HIRED A LAWYER, LEARNED
AMERICAN HISTORY AND SWORN
ALLEGIANCE TO THIS GREAT NATION.
TOMORROW THEN AM I INTERESTED IN
EVEN TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
ENTERING.
I FOR ONE AM SICK AND TIRED OF
THE SENSE OF ENTITLEMENT THAT
ILLEGALS HAVE TO ENTER THIS
COUNTRY THEN IMMEDIATELY CLAIM
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AS
THEY CARRY THE FLAGS NOT OF
AMERICA, BUT THE FLAGS OF THEIR
COUNTRY.
GOD FORBID IF WE TRY TO DEPORTED
THEM TO THE FLAG OF THE COUNTRY
THEY SO PROUDLY WAVE.
THEY BREAK OUR LAWS TO COME
HERE.
THEY ARE NOT ENTITLED TO COME
THIS IS NOT A LEFT OR RIGHT
ISSUE.
THIS IS A SECURITY ISSUE.
A SAFETY ISSUE.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT HAVE PEOPLE
ABOUT WHOM WE KNOW NOTHING
LIVING NEXT DOOR TO US, WORKING
NEXT TO US OR DRIVING NEXT TO
US.
CROSSERS CLAIM THEY ARE RUNNING
FROM VIOLENCE IN THEIR OWN
COUNTRIES.
I SPENT MY CAREER HELPING
VICTIMS OF CRIMES.
CRIMINALS WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
STOPPED LONG BEFORE THE CRIME.
YOU ARE TELLING ME BECAUSE THEY
ARE BEING VICTIM IETDS THAT
EVERY ONE OF THEM IS A VICTIM
AND ENTITLED TO COME HERE AS
OPPOSED TO ANYWHERE ELSE ON THE
PLANET?
GO TO THE U.N., STAY IN MEXICO.
NOW, THEY SAY THEIR POVERTY IS
JUSTIFICATION FOR ILLEGAL ENTRY.
I HAVE GOT NEWS FOR YOU.
MILLIONS ARE SUFFERING FROM
POVERTY ALL OVER THE WORLD.
HAITI, UGANDA, ZIMBABWE, THE
CONGO, THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES.
WHY IS IT JUST CENTRAL AMERICANS
AND MEXICANS ARE THE POVERTY
STRICKEN ONES POURING INTO THIS
COUNTRY BY THE MILLIONS?
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY CAN.
BECAUSE NO ONE HAS TOLD THEM
THEY CAN'T.
BECAUSE NO ONE HAS STOPPED THEM.
THEY COME BECAUSE THERE IS A BIG
PRIZE AT THE END.
EDUCATION, MEDICATION, HOUSING,
FOOD STAMPS, ALL THE THINGS YOU
PAY FOR.
SO YOU WANT OPEN BORDERS.
LOOK AT WHAT IT'S DONE TO
EUROPE.
IF THE LEFT, THE MOB, AND THE
DEMON RATS HAVE THEIR WAY, THERE
WOULD BE ROGUE CITIES AND ROGUE
ZONES ALL OVER THE U.S. JUST
LIKE EUROPE WITH CRIME-RIDDEN
ZONES WHERE LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE AFRAID
TO ENTER, AND FOR GOOD REASON.
THE LEFT THEN, THE DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY ADD AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF PROTECTION SO ILLEGAL
CRIMINALS CAN NOT ARRESTED IN
SANCTUARY CITIES AND STATES
WHERE AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE PUT
AT RISK.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T WANT A BORDER
WALL.
IF YOU EVER ASKED YOURSELF WHY?
DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL OR IDEOLOGICAL
OBJECTION TO THE CONCEPT OF A
WALL OR PROTECTION?
OF COURSE NOT.
ALL THESE BOZOS ARE PROTECTED BY
DOORS AND FENCES AND SECURITY.
BUT THEY WANT OUR BORDERS OPEN,
THEY WANT ILLEGALS TO CROSS AS A
MOB AND ACT LIKE A MOB AND YOU
NIGHT AROUND A STATE THEY HAVE
NO RIGHT TO BE IN AND REGISTER
AND VOTE DEMOCRAT.
MANY BRIT POISON DRUGS THAT TAKE
THE LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS.
90% OF HEROIN USE IN THIS
COUNTRY COMES THROUGH THE ON
BORED AND MEXICO THUMBS ITS
NOLES AT US AND SAYS YOUR PEOPLE
ASK FOR IT.
I HAVE GOT AN IDEA.
IT'S TIME TO PLAY HARDBALL.
THE FOREIGN AID TO THOSE
COUNTRIES, $464 MILLION IN
FOREIGN AID FROM US TO
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS AND EL
SALVADOR.
END IT.
IF THEY NEED IT SO BADLY USE TO
IT TAKE CARE OF THE POVERTY AND
VICTIMIZATION IN THEIR COUNTRY.
I'M SICK AND TIRED OF PEOPLE
TELLING TO US HAVE A HEART.
WE HAVE A HEART.
WE ARE THE MOST OF GENEROUS
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
IN 1986 RONALD REAGAN GAVE ALL
ILLEGALS AMNESTY.
BUT AMNESTY DOES NOTHING BUT
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
ADDITIONAL CROSSING BY ILLEGALS
SO HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
FOR ALL OF YOU WHO WANT TO TRASH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I HAVE GOT EVEN
MORE NEWS FOR YOU.
PRESIDENTS BUSH AND OBAMA SENT
THE MILITARY TO THE BORDER TO
THE TUNE OF $1.3 BILLION.
AND IT'S TIME TO DO IT AGAIN.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
WHEN YOU CROSS THE BORDER INTO
THESE UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY,
EXPECT TO BE ARRESTED.
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
HERE.
WE DID NOT INVITE YOU HERE.
YOU CANNOT STAY HERE.
JOHN WAY OUT, YOU CAN TELL THE
DEMOCRAT GEORGE SOROS AND THE
ANGRY MOB COMING HERE, YOU
EITHER COME THE RIGHT WAY LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE OR BE READY TO